sigamos evaluando expresiones que tienen
muchas variables desconocidas en este
caso nos dan 3 x 3 37 igual a 1 y 12 x
12 y 12 z que será igual y te voy a dar
unos segundos para que pienses en esta
pauta vamos a reescribir esta expresión
que se encuentra aquí actualizando el 12
y tenemos 12 veces x + + z y puedes
verificar distribuyendo el 12 que
obtenemos exactamente lo que está aquí
ahora veamos cuánto es 12 veces x + de
maceta y pues la verdad todavía no lo
sabemos pero esta primera ecuación puede
ser de utilidad
esta primera ecuación también la podemos
reescribir factor izando el 3 y entonces
quedaría del lado izquierdo 3 veces x +
+ z igual a 1 lo único que hice fue
factorizar y ahora para resolver x más
de maceta que puedo dividir ambos lados
entre 3
entonces me quedara x jay-z es igual a
un tercio y ahora regresando a nuestra
otra ecuación en vez de x maceta puedo
sustituirlo por un tercio y vemos que
todo se simplificó a 12 veces un tercio
que es lo mismo que 12 veces entre 3 que
es igual a 4
intentemos una nueva en esta nos dicen
que 3 a 5 b es igual a 2 y nos preguntan
15 a más 15 b a que será igual
te voy a dar unos segundos para que lo
pienses
bueno como en los ejemplos anteriores yo
podría tomar esta expresión de aquí y
restaurarla como 15 veces a más veces y
si yo supiera el valor de ambas b ya
estaría listo y entonces pues podríamos
regresar a nuestra primera ecuación
intentando reescribir la en términos de
hamás b
entonces si yo factorizar el 3 y me
quedaría como 3 veces a más cinco
tercios de b
lo cual no parece ayudar mucho
y de la misma manera si yo quiero
factorizar el 5 me va a quedar cinco
veces tres quintos de hamás b es igual a
dos y como se puede ver ninguna de estas
dos resulta en la forma que queremos ver
solo a más 20 así que mejor escribimos y
no tenemos suficiente información para
resolver bueno con suerte también te
pareció interesante